so thank you for staying for the last
session of the day it's been a very long
day for very serious talks so let me
introduce myself I am marina Guevara
I work in the Alan Turing Institute in
London which is the British National
Institute for data science and
artificial intelligence and I work there
as a data scientist and that's normal
serious work but outside of that I like
to play with actual interesting data
[Music]
[Music]
I'm pretty sure that's the name they are
going to use for next movie so this is
the first time we have seen it so let's
talk about Star Wars who loved Star Wars
I certainly do
so when I was thinking so as a data
scientist what kind of data can I
actually analyze around Star Wars well
of course there are the movies but
that's kind of like movies you can't
really stick them into our or something
and do something cool with that and then
I realized that all movies have scripts
screenplays and you can actually get
them online and there are a couple of
websites that published scripts I'm not
sure what's the legal standing of them
well actually the scripts appear that
are usually very like very quickly after
the movie comes out I was actually
really disappointed that a script of the
last Jedi didn't appear there yet so my
analysis that doesn't include the
lightest film so I actually download the
script and if you look at a script it
has a very nice standardized format all
scenes start with int or X meaning
interior or exterior then there is the
name of the scene there is some
description and then there are the
people speaking and their names are
always in both capitals in the center
that's pretty easy right and I thought
okay so what can I do with this well I
can parse the screen scenes I can get
the people talking in each scene and
then maybe I can even construct a social
network by looking at characters that
speak together in a scene and then I
would get social network of the whole
Star Wars universe sounds pretty easy
right so I looked at the scripts as they
were published online and they were
really nice HTML pre formatted blocks of
text with as I said the scenes in both
capitals here and names in both capitals
that's easy
so I wrote a parser for that I ran it on
all the scripts and it didn't work
because obviously in data science 90% of
the work is data wrangling and 10% is
complaining about data wrangling
so let me complain a little I rendered
my program on all the scripts and for
example episode 3 of the prequels came
up with this script
and suddenly the names of the characters
were in both capitals again but they
were followed by a colon and then what
the characters were speaking so that's
not very helpful I wrote another parser
and had a set of regular expressions and
it didn't work either so I looked at
some of the names and for example here
the second character is not a free case
I it's a lowercase L her
that's this scary guy by the way
yeah so I rewrote the parser again ran
it again with all of exceptions for the
characters that didn't quite fit in and
then oh I looked at the resulting
networks and something just wasn't right
because some of the crucial characters
were missing like r2d2 or Chewbacca okay
what's happening there like why did my
algorithm miss it so I looked into the
script and they come the name things
like artoo frantically beeps something
that's not very helpful and Chewbacca
barks a comment and Han says boy you
said it Chewie no you didn't
[Laughter]
so I appreciate that the actors did a
really good job interpreting these
scripts on the screen but for me as a
data scientist that's not very helpful
so I thought okay but I can't create a
social network of the Star Wars
characters and miss Chewbacca or r2d2 so
what I did I actually decided to
basically estimate how many times this
character would have spoken if they have
spoken in the script so I did that by
estimating okay how many times a
character is mentioned in a scene how
does it compare with the number of times
the character actually speaks in the
scene and I came up with some really
really complicated mathematics and turns
out basically characters are usually
mentioned two times as much as they
speak so that allowed me to basically
who impede these characters that don't
speak explicitly into the scene by
mentioning by looking at how many times
they were mentioned so good I'm ready to
go except yeah Wow Chewbacca is happy
because he got into the social network
some characters didn't make it so if you
liked evokes they don't speak in the
scripts either but I just didn't have
enough patience just get all of them in
so I'm sorry and some characters messed
up my implementation again because if
you have seen episode 7 Star Wars Luke
Skywalker
looks very dramatic here they talk about
him a lot but he doesn't speak a single
word so he must have my algorithms again
but in the end I managed to get all the
characters but I could ended up with a
lot of strings that I thought were
characters so I thought okay so what can
I actually do with this how can I
validate it something or someone is a
character in Star Wars
well my theorem is that there is an API
for everything similarly like in our
there is a package for everything there
is an API for everything so there is an
API for Star Wars
and if you go to swap Adagio you get the
Star Wars API okay I can use this to
validate my characters I looked at the
website they have very nice
documentation they have wrappers for the
API and things like our and cetera I
thought okay maybe I should want should
use just one of these but then where's
the fun in that
and to be honest I didn't do this stuff
in our so all the code is actually very
boring if you look at all the wrappers
so I will actually show you some of the
code that I wrote for it but it will be
in F sharp which is a functional
programming language it's statically
typed and it has some really really cool
features for working with data and I
will basically write part of my from a
provider that will give me access to the
API directly here if my internet
connection works so because F sharp is a
statically typed language
I will first create a type for my
rest-based API let's call it a person
because I will get information on people
and API returns a JSON so I would create
something called adjacent provider and I
will just give it the URL of the API
alright and I am basically all set
because right now I can just type create
a function to get me all the information
based on an ID and the only thing I need
to do is load the correct URL and
because F sharp is a statically typed
language with type inference I have to
change the ID to a string and now let's
get a person called X
let's get the first person okay I
haven't done anything right now I
haven't run anything I just wrote some
code and now if I do X dot it
immediately tells me what's in the Jason
I didn't run anything what's happened
it's magic and the great thing is it
also tells me the types of things so for
example height is an integer you can see
it in the pop-up thing and gender is a
string I color is a string as well
I still haven't run anything I don't
know who this person is and if I look at
the name name is again a string that's
really cool the thing why you
I used F sharp for this is that it gives
me access to everything it interfers the
types I can write my code I can do
anything cool with that and I can run it
afterwards and I'm sure it will work
because it looked at the Chasen format
and infrared everything so I basically
went on and created a wrapper for the
whole thing and it took me 67 lines most
of them are not very interesting
basically just calling the Jason type
provider and now I have all the cool
information about Star Wars characters
so that's actually around something
let's download information on all the
people and what appeared down there is
the F sharp repo okay now I have
information on all the 87 characters
that are in the API and I can find out
all sorts of interesting information you
always wanted to know about Star Wars
characters like what's the most common
eye color and the most common eye color
among Star Wars characters is brown
because for example Han Solo has brown
eyes
Yoda has brown eyes in case you wondered
the second most common is blue and the
third most common color is yellow so
Darth Vader has yellow eyes I'm not sure
how they managed to find that that out
and I can also
validate all sorts of interesting
information for example in the original
New Hope Star Wars Episode four Luke
Skywalker wants to rescue Princess Leia
and he dresses as a stormtrooper and he
rushes into her cell and she's like
aren't you a bit short for a
stormtrooper
we can validate that so let's look at
Luke Skywalker and Luke Skywalker his
height is 172 centimeters I'm not sure
how much that is
in the imperial units sorry I'm European
and I can look at the average height of
a Star Wars character not just on drew
processor II but the average height is
174 centimeters so yes Leia was right
Luke Skywalker is a bit short
[Laughter]
revalidated that all right so then I
went on and did a pull request and now F
sharp rapper is there on the suavi
website as well so now I had all the
scenes and all the characters extracted
from that I thought okay so what can I
do next with the data and then I saw a
very cool analysis online done by
polygraph where they looked at
screenplays and they extracted
characters and looked at their gender
and look at how much men speak in films
and how much for him and speak in films
it was a bit depressing because they
looked at Disney films and in most of
the fairy tales it's actually just male
characters speaking all the time so I
thought okay let's how look how it looks
for Star Wars and this is a graph from
starting from episode 1 to episode 7 and
these are all characters that speak in
at least two scenes that have explicit
name in the script and you can see that
it only improved a little in Episode
seven but in the original Star Wars like
83% of all the characters speaking where
males
it looks like space is for men only
and I'm sorry I just looked at men
versus everyone else so I grouped women
and robots and I'm not sure who should I
apologize to so then I had all the data
and the first thing that everyone does
when they have a data set is to
visualize that so finally let's look at
the whole Star Wars universe opened so
this is a d3 visualization of the Star
Wars Network I can move it around it's
also fun for me to play with so this is
the network of the original Star Wars
movie episode for new hope and you can
see that there are a couple of major
characters they have fairly strong links
between them and then there are a couple
of minor characters around this little
node that's not connected to anyone is a
character that doesn't speak to anyone
else in their scene which is one of the
resistance pilots that appears they're
only in a cockpit and doesn't speak to
anyone else so this is how it compares
to the first episode of the prequels The
Phantom Menace you can see oh that's
that's a huge network as for this one
there are major characters they are
fairly densely connected but base why
whoa what's happening there and this is
how it compares to Episode seven you can
see that there are quite a lot of
characters but definitely less than in
the Phantom Menace
so can we quantify that actually how do
the movies differ in numbers and
basically my hidden goal was let's prove
that the prequels were rubbish
using data science so this is the size
of the networks just the number of
characters that appear there and as I
said these are characters that have
explicit names in the scripts so nothing
like a strong trooper but Han Solo
Chewbacca etc and they have to speak in
at least two scenes and you can see that
in episode one the number is the highest
than in the original trilogy which are
these three it's a bit smaller and then
Episode seven it jumps up again and to
make it even more explicit this is the
number of characters per a minute of
screen time so in the episode 1 of the
prequels there are almost one character
almost every three minutes that's way
too much so what can we do next I
decided to look at some network
characteristics so the first one was
density if you have an example network
like this density basically just
compares the number of connections that
are in the network with the number of
connections that could be in the network
this is how we do it mathematically the
interpretation in terms of the story is
that network is very dense that means
everyone is talking to everyone else if
it's very sparse
it means the characters just don't talk
to each other and this is how it looks
for the movies and again for the two
first movies and prequels they have the
lowest density that means they have way
too many characters that don't stock to
each other and then the density is
higher for all the subsequent episodes
and it was the highest for episode sakes
maybe because I discarded all the evokes
sorry again so then I decided to look at
their like local structure so I would
have a indicator called the clustering
coefficient so what it means is
basically looks at if your friends know
each other or not so this green guy in
the corner
he has three friends and two of them
don't know each other
and this guy has three friends again but
they do know each other so the
clustering coefficient basically
quantifies that you look at the number
of neighbors and how many of your
neighbors know each other and in terms
of the story if a network has a very low
clustering coefficient it means it
follows one character that talks to
other characters but these characters
don't talk to each other they don't know
each other they don't have any backstory
and if a network has a high question
coefficient that means and everyone
talks to everyone well I'm sure you can
imagine by now how it looks it's the
lowest for the prequels and then it goes
out in the other episodes so the
prequels were rubbish based on this as
well because there are just way too many
characters that don't talk to each other
and then in Episode seven it dropped
again so I can't quantify that for the
episode eight because I don't have the
screenplay yet and then I decided to
look at the most crucial question so who
is the most central in the Star Wars
universe so the most straightforward
measure is the degree where you
basically just look at the number of
neighbors so this guy is very central
because he knows six people and this guy
is less central because he knows only
three nodes so that's a very
straightforward thing and then I decided
to compare that with something called
betweenness and this measure tells you
how in between other characters someone
is so if I look at this guy and these
two other guys
he's very crucial for them because if
they want to talk to each other they
have to go through the green guy and if
I take these two guys the green guy is
not that crucial for them because they
have other ways of communicating as well
so this basically tells you how central
a character is in the story how much the
character compared they connect
different communities so this is how you
compute it mathematically but the
crucial thing is that you have to
compute the shortest paths between nodes
and that's quite a lot of work already
so the great thing in R is that there is
a package for everything so I use the I
graft package
and as I said I was doing some of it in
f-sharp
so basically I just called it from
f-sharp and we have a tie provider for
that like the Jason type provider I was
showing you before there is a tie
provider for our as well so you just
type our dot and you get access to
everything you have in your our
installation so that was easy and this
is how it looks for episode 7 so if I
just look at the degree the most central
character is Poe Dameron which is one of
the resistance pilots and then you have
all the other characters but you can see
that the main characters are actually
not there if you have seen episode seven
if you haven't I'm sorry but if you look
at betweenness suddenly kylo Ren is the
second and Trey is the third so this
measure captures much more how a
character is crucial in the story how
the character connects different
communities so but Poe is still the most
central character there so he's
celebrating and now you might ask so who
is the most central of the whole network
well before episode 7 it was this guy
obi-wan Kenobi but then he died in
episode 4 so he probably can't continue
being the most central so when I
actually included episode 7 that ah
Darth Vader still rules the galaxy so as
Jared mentioned everyone wants to talk
to me about Star Wars and actually this
is I did normal sadistic PhD but this is
my most academically successful work to
be honest because I put all the networks
in adjacent format on my github with a
permissive Creative Commons license and
turns out people are using these
networks for education to teach people
network science as an example data set
and then they have a higher headache
because they are trying to figure out
how to actually cite github or my blog
post in their academic papers and this
being this has been pretty successful
and it was also published in the actual
paper magazine in pro science which is a
French version of the Scientific
American so I was pretty excited about
that
they sent me a paper copy Wow I did this
while I was in Cambridge and when I
actually read it I don't speak any
French but I'm pretty sure this doesn't
say Cambridge so my takeaway message for
you is to like put your data out because
people will use them for their own means
they will get it wrong but they will use
them and then it was useful for me as
well because back then I was doing
cancer research and I was reading a
paper and I looked at some of the
figures there and they were trying to
predict oncogenes and tumor suppressor
genes and they were trying to predict a
network between them and then they had
this figure there where they claimed
that tumor suppressors and oncogenes
have higher betweenness in their
networks and like betweenness I know
this from Star Wars so I think there is
a lot of value it's playing with actual
interpretable datasets because sometimes
you just run an algorithm that you don't
really understand that while on your
customer database or on some gene
database something comes out and you
don't really understand the results but
in case of Star Wars you probably do so
play with interpretive real data search
please and if you want to talk about
Star Wars or anything else just find me
later or ping me on Twitter or anything
and made the RB with you
you
you